>> So Haiti, obviously breaks my heart.
And it deserves to be on the agenda here in
Davos.
But in many ways, it's an old story.
Haiti is less about the tragedy, this crisis,
the 100,000, almost
200,000 people, their lives lost, a needless
tragedy.
And the same crisis, the same magnitude earthquake
or thereabouts hit
San Francisco in 1989 hit Haiti, but in San
Francisco 68 people, I
believe that's the number, 68 died.
Certainly less than a hundred.
In Haiti, almost 200,000 people have died.
The problem with Haiti is poverty.
It's not that Haitians are any less intelligent
or any less ambitious,
it's that they're less able and less capable
to fend for themselves as
a result of that environment of poverty, you
have poor infrastructure,
poor government, poor government building,
poor standards, poor values,
poor investment.
And if you go back to when Haiti was an economic
leader for the
colonies European colonies several hundred
years ago, they were doing
really well into a war and beat Napoleon,
the only country to beat
Napoleon.
And some would say as a result of that, some
European interests made
them pay a price which was economic.
They're still paying that price today.
We have a chance to do it right and get to
right again, to make sure
this never happens to Haiti again or any other
place that's vulnerable
in the world by going in.
After we stabilized and after we help people
in this crisis.
Let's not just give them sympathy.
Let's give them empathy.
Let's give them a hand up and not just a hand
out.
Let's not just be the Good Samaritan along
the Jericho.
Let's fix the Jericho road.
Let's go in and give them roads and gutters
and streetlights.
Let's give them safe environments.
Let's give them an opportunity for home ownership
and individual
property rights and small business ownership
and entrepreneurship and
self-employment projects.
Because there's not enough jobs to go around
in corporations, we know
in Haiti, you're not going to save them in
government largesse can't
and shouldn't save them.
We should give people the dignity of being
able to do for themselves.
So I think that we should really maybe look
at free enterprise and
capitalism, work for the poor in Haiti, over
the next 2 to 10 years, it
should be a massive serious campaign to empower
the Haitian people with
dignity.
It's a boon to I and me because you are you.
I know President Clinton and UN envoy is doing
his part.
I know there are certain committee members
here but you are the first
to hear that Operation Hope, the organization
that I founded that
serves 1,100,000 people will be going into
Haiti with a massive
five-year campaign to make free enterprise
and capitalism work for the
people, to teach a generation of young people
financial literacy and
the language of money and give them the dignity
and the ability to do
for themselves.
Thank you.